what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today
I pissed off the religious people
now
before I start you know don't forget to
subscribe like the video all that stuff
but today I pissed off the religious
people now
before I start I want to give a
background on my stance on religion okay
now I grew up Catholic I did 12 Years of
Catholic school and I think Catholic
like just in my heart of hearts is my
favorite religion now after
um a bit I did go Christian for a bit
and the reason was it was kind of a
stupid reason and I think religious
people will get mad at me for this
reason but I hated Catholic mass it was
so boring
um now in hindsight I actually think
maybe I could do I could um
use maybe in my life a bit more silence
and reflection it'd probably be good for
me but
the Christians you know they they just
they had a fun Mass there was so much
more community so I went there okay and
I went there for a couple years and I
was super into Christianity um like I
was super I prayed a lot I did Bible
study once a week I went to church on
Sundays and I was really good
until I came to England I won't lie to
you guys I have to be honest I have to
be honest
um and there was some stuff I want to
talk about with the Christian church
but um when I came to England the shows
started on Saturday nights
and
it just got in the way I just I'm not a
morning person I couldn't get to mass I
don't I don't want to say could it
because that sounds like I didn't choose
that I didn't right now I think I
actually was thinking of switching my
shows to Friday night so I could go
again because most of my life I did go
to church but the last couple years some
things in the religion just kind of off
put me and I couldn't figure out what I
couldn't figure out like what was
off-putting to me but I'm just like I
smell right there's some things
and I just like I hear and I just smell
and hear nonsense and I would go to
church and like certain things would
just rub me the wrong way but I didn't
know what and I couldn't explain why
until I read the rational males
book on religion
now right now you know he's been
tweeting about me some not so nice
things don't really appreciate that
but I can't I can't help with the men
are tweeting you know what I mean I
can't I cannot stop the tweets so
but outside of that he's he's a genius
he's a very smart man and he talked
about how like church is basically
they're not patriarchies and a lot of
them are indoctrinating us into like
liberal ideas so for example now we see
the gay flags in church we see the
ex-porn star Pastor wives and like some
things are just kind of like nice and
down for women and I remember like in
high school we would have these Chastity
speakers and it would always be like the
girl that got ran through and then she
would get married after and I don't
think that's a good message right that
like you can do whatever you want and as
long as you pray and say sorry there's a
light at the end of the tunnel I think
that the message should be as a woman if
you sleep with too many people you're
ruined you ruined yourself for your
future husband and there probably isn't
a light at the end of the tunnel and the
guy that you're gonna get is
significantly of lower even the guy you
would have gotten
now
I say this and then I start thinking are
the top men the most sought after men in
society going to wait for a virgin
will they even believe the girls that
they're virgins
I don't know but that's a whole
different conversation right that's a
whole different
but I think in general we should
push the women to wait till they're
married I think that's better you know I
didn't do that I wish I did right okay
but
but my point is this
Christianity like the liberalism I could
just feel it in my soul and when I was
in that Christian Church there would be
these super nice girls that like were
allegedly like virgin like they had all
the wifey qualities you'd think you'd
want but for some reason like there's 25
to 28-ish year old virgins that weren't
married and it's just like why aren't
where are the masculine men in the
church and a lot of the guys were just
kind of simpy you know
um okay so let's get to the part where I
piss the religious people off
so this came this idea came to me from I
was watching this YouTube video and
there was a pastor on there okay and
there's this pastor and he was talking
about how he's like I and and they
always they come off so weird like he's
like I would never work with someone
that cheats on his wife I don't surround
myself with people like that
and I'm like okay well you know
um and gosh I I hate talking about
cheating I talk about it a lot because
it's not the hill I want to die on I
don't think cheating is good
but I think a lot of times we demonize
men who cheat as if they're so evil and
awful and we don't talk about how even
Christian women have social media which
is attention seeking even if you're not
like posting like thirst traps and
whatever like it's a bit hypocritical
of wait wait
of the women to say oh cheating is the
worst thing ever when they have open
Instagram accounts and we could say well
what if her butt's not on it well her
face is still on it
and you know I mean that's still in a
way attention seek you know and again
this isn't to like put them down but
it's more to show the double like the
hypocrisy right is this crazy I don't
know maybe I'm just nuts and I think
like this but this pastor was saying
that cheating is like the worst thing
ever I don't surround with men that
cheat men that cheat like have horrible
morals and I'm thinking okay all right
so we got I have a notebook to to
demonstrate this idea we have two men
all right so and this pastor got married
in his 30s all right so
I was thinking and like he got saved
then or whatever which and I'm not even
saying it's not genuine but I'm just
saying I want the religious people to
hear how this comes across
so I'm gonna put a Jesus cross next to
this guy so this is the can we see this
this is the
and I hope my phone doesn't die this is
the religious man this is the not
religious man this is the cheater this
is the religious man so
he'll say things like I'm a one-woman
man okay but he got married at 32.
okay guy one got married let's say he
got married at 18. but let's say in his
40-year marriage he stepped out twice so
there was he had his wife here we're
gonna do a little
he had his wife here okay can we see
this and then he had to you know
maybe he had a chick at work
and he had a chick there right now the
man that got married at 32 let's say
he's still you know a quote-unquote one
woman type of man
but he still dated and you know let's
just be honest here in general
sex comes before relationships so he's
as a guy let's just say now I know and I
know all the people are going to say
Pearl
the
Pearl like like there's not a lot of men
that can do this okay and I know but
this was just inspired by this one video
I saw now the 32 year old let's just say
before he got married he slept with one
girl a year from the time he was 18.
which is a bit conservative if he's
because I'm just thinking if he's a
preacher right women love men on a stage
they love men on a stage all right they
love it so and look at I'm not even
saying I'm special but so let's just say
he slept with from
18 19 20 20 and 22 that's four sorry I'm
bad amount so 14 women
all right
four five
all right one two three four five six
seven
eight
eight nine ten
eleven
twelve
thirteen
fourteen okay now I just want to put
visuals to this these are the women he's
been involved with these are the women
cheaters been involved and you could
argue that the cheater probably has to
be more careful and it's less women
because if he's going home to his wife
every night like he can't really bring
women like that and you know men have to
earn sex so it's like you'd have to go
out like so he's just he got the strange
the two you know
all right and so guy a will say I'm a
type of man
because he has
he has to let's just say 42. but are you
a one-woman type of man
like like my question is is he better
than the cheater
now like because I'll heal the argument
right I'll hear the argument well one of
them took a vow and I think that's fair
your word is important as a guy
but what I'm looking at is the outcomes
which one contributed to more STDs which
one contributed to more abortions now
you could argue that well I would never
ask a girl to do that well you don't
know if she did right you know you don't
know she's not required to tell you
which one contributed to more degeneracy
and so you see like it's like so these
guys will come in and act like they're
on this like moral High Ground
when really they're kind of the same
just in a different way
and in a way the cheater probably
contributed to less degeneracy than he
did
now I don't know if this is a crazy
thought
but I was just thinking like how can you
say your your monogamous or a one-woman
type of guy if you didn't pick monogamy
now again I don't even really blame the
guys for this because they just adapt to
the market
um and you know women like there's
there's all these different my my issue
was when he was saying like it's like we
act like the men that cheat are so
horrible and it can't happen and we
don't act like the women who have open
Instagrams and like I'll see it on
Twitter like the Trad wives
and I don't even again I'm not even
trying to demonize them because I also
have social media but it's like they'll
say oh the men are so horrible for
cheating but I'm like Diane you don't
have to have your face on social media
you could take off your face and still
tweet comments and like you you don't
have to have your face at all on it like
there's people that build followings
with no face
so are you that much better
than the guy that's cheating
I don't know and guys I I'm not trying
to die on this hill okay I promise you
like I really don't care that much about
about cheating or like whatever but for
me it's more it's more what I'm calling
out is the double standard where this
priest will be on this moral High Ground
when he's probably or not sorry not
priest um preacher whatever this dude so
I watch this YouTube video and this
guy's like yeah I would never work with
someone that's horrible morals now then
there's the third guy okay there's the
third guy I actually I want to do the
third guy now this is the guy
that couldn't get laid
so this is the third preacher we're
gonna put a church a church guy
these are the men
that marry the born-again Virgin so they
come in
and he's only slept with let's just say
one one woman
she might be a virgin but like the the
guys over here
degenerate whatever like I don't even
want to say degenerate but you
understand where I'm coming from maybe
the other guys
like the other the guys that do get
women say well it's easy for you to push
monogamy because women don't want you
you have no other option
and then guys over here will say I'm on
this moral High Ground because I I don't
I don't cheat when they're like well do
women even want you and again I'm
butchering the religious stuff but
didn't that Solomon guy have like a
million wives and I know Jesus I think
condemned that or there's the one guy
that married like the old woman and then
had like Kane and Abel I think whatever
but
I know and Jesus like did say that was
wrong I think anyway so I'm sorry if I'm
butchering this the religious people get
so heated that it's tough to have these
convos because if you get one part wrong
they're like ah
I'm sorry I just asked questions but
Jesus didn't come in and say I won't do
business with you I won't work for you
through you like even though Solomon had
all the concubines and stuff he still
was a great man and did a bunch of good
so to say I can't surround myself with
these immoral men when men do have a
predisposition to do that type of stuff
now that's not saying it's okay please
stop taking my words out of context
but it's more my argument is I think we
need to demonize people
the same way we humanize women who make
mistakes like I think we can humanize
men who make mistakes and understand
where they're coming from and try to
work through it is that crazy
I don't know
um
but let me know who who is more of a
one-woman man
actually like genuinely who is more of a
one-woman man when it comes to outcomes
the man who slept with 15 girls
and then 32 got married and has been
faithful for 10 years
or
the man who had one woman and cheated
twice
who is more of the
because I would argue that someone
that's been in the streets for 10 to 15
years
likely has had more sexual partners than
a cheater because again the cheater has
the wife at home he can't be out like
that I don't know this is just me
thinking let me know if I'm crazy maybe
I'm just nuts I don't know I'm just
thinking like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification Bell I'll talk to you next
time